what's the matter what you love flarb
it's to Larbi not larvae enough how many
times you have to say the larb before
you talk to me no i larb you Irish
stress the internship and I'm tired
this dark internship I have to tell you
not a fan of that Tony Stark after an
ATM robbery was thwarted by queen's own
beautiful local crime stopper the
spider-man
that's not something like that happen I
telling you how long last was that
off-site yeah yeah yeah of course six
blocks away from us we didn't order that
some house oh thanks he'll arms you the
joint venture between Stark Industries
in the federal government the Department
of damage control will oversee the
collection and storage of alien and
other exotic materials tech spurts
estimate there are over 1500 tons of
exotic materials scattered throughout
the tri-state area hey chief you still
of another load from yesterday you're
supposed to turn this in right I ain't
all in it it's too bad
could have made some pretty cool stuff
from all that alien junk I'd say what
let's keep it the world's changing
it's time we change too
[Music]
duh nothing you're the spider-man
I'm not sealing wasn't it what are you
doing in my room mailing me and you said
we're gonna finish the Death Star she
doesn't know no I mean mrs. Stewart
knows doesn't mean my super - yeah mr.
Glee - that are you an Avenger ha
basically this guy keep a secret I'll
level with you
I don't think this'll secretly slick
reducing has ever happened to me i'ma
say about this is school tomorrow
okay great can you spit phantom you have
any idea no can you summon an army of
spiders no Ned do you know him - I still
wish you taping me up he stopped huh
Marilyn what's there no no evil air give
a letter dude again with alien guns run
by a guy with wings yeah they have a
lair but uh but how are you gonna get
there force like 300 miles away it's not
too far from DC hey Pizza gosh waiter
yeah I was hoping maybe I could rejoin
the team oh no way
you can't just quit on a stroll up and
be welcomed back by everyone hey welcome
back Peter flash you're back to first
alternate what he's making a place in
Sumy can we go already cuz I was hoping
to get in some light protesting kind of
wanted to Embassy's what weird inner
chef protesting is patriotic let's get
on the bus Wow look at that new guy
who's that that's my cue I gotta go find
Captain American I stole his shield with
swords amazing thing that's ever
happened to mrs. Oakes like Andrews and
I just sort of flipped in hey jeez a
second coming hey death in Walsall the
bridge the powerful I don't care about
us with pickup after with eat their
table scraps these alien bastards are
tough you got to use the stuff they use
the world's change this time we change
waiting for next mission we'll call you
kick it a little more med touring be
real-ass 62 that's not a hug I'm just
grabbing the tow for you
oh all right kid good luck out there
someone is collecting stuff from
Avengers battles I'm building these
crazy weapons this is my chance to prove
myself
what if somebody had died to different
story right cuz that's on you I wanted
you to be better eight years let in
trouble for those bozos up in stark
tower and it's all bastard red tights
shows up
he thinks he can tear down everything
I'd go
full of brand-new Avengers weaponry
dallona
where to put him out of business we're
gonna take everything they got
[Music]
do you know him - yeah still issue
[Music]
you